toufik thani président d'honneur de
l'association france palestine
solidarité bonsoir tawfiq henni merci
d'être avec nous clairement beaucoup de
tensions il y aurait une neuf morts dont
un commandant but du hamas clairement ce
soir doit-on craindre une troisième
intifada que l'on craint d'ailleurs
depuis déjà plusieurs années
neuf morts dont trois enfants en bas âge
les photos qui circulent déjà sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est à dire que israël
quand elles bombardent elle bombarde
sans distinction c'est une punition
collective qui touche tout le monde et
donc il ya trois enfants qui sont qui
sont morts et puis d'autres civils au
total ça fait 9
est ce qu'on peut craindre une intifada
observer les ingrédients d'un
soulèvement palestinien il existe depuis
très longtemps et cette cette question
qui est question qui est centrale
palestinienne n'a jamais perdu de sa
centralité elle n'a jamais trouvé
vraiment un écho auprès des décideurs du
monde entier de temps en temps il ya des
résolutions qui appelle israël à
respecter le droit international mais
qui nomme qui ne sont jamais appliquées
et la maintenance récemment netanyahu
qui ont difficultés électorales
il voulait créer un problème à jérusalem
pour détourner l'attention de l'opinion
publique et israéliennes palestiniennes
et internationales sur ses déboires avec
la justice donc il a allumé le feu parce
qu'il faut qu'on sache un petit peu
comment ces événements ils ont commencé
c'était au début du ramadan donc il y
avait la fermeture de la place place
devant la porte de damas aux
palestiniens qui la fréquentent souvent
tous les mois du ramadan pour discuter
un peu entre eux entre
la recrue du jeune et puis en attendant
la dernière prière de la nuit donc ça a
été fermée comme ça gratuitement de des
palestiniens et en même temps il y avait
cette manifestation d' extrémistes
israéliens de groupes de fascistes donc
d'ailleurs aux cris de mort aux arabes
et puis des scènes de ratonnades contre
les palestiniens donc ça a commencé par
les provocations et du gouvernement et
de la police
il serait bien et puis également des
collants qui était épaulé par passe est
cette même ce même gouvernement donc il
y avait une provocation vis-à-vis des
palestiniens
s'ajoutent à ceux ci ce qui se passe
dans le quartier de sheikh jarrah parce
que ça c'est ce qui a poussé un petit
peu les parisiens à dire basta pourquoi
nous on n'a pas le droit à une vie qui
correct comme le reste de l'humanité
pourquoi les palestiniens qui habitent
dans la résidence depuis 1948
lorsqu'ils ont été expulsés d'israël et
puis qui ont eu le droit d'avoir des
maisons avec un accord entre la jordanie
et l'onu en 1956 pourquoi maintenant il
faut qu'ils soient expulsés de chez eux
pour donner c'est leur maison à des
colons juifs qui viennent d'ailleurs
donc vous voyez il ya ces ingrédients du
soulèvement populaire il existe depuis
longtemps les palestiniens ne veulent
pas mal est fait ça ne veulent pas
exposer leur vie comme ça à des tirs à
balles réelles ou bâle
d'ailleurs c'est indépendant caoutchouc
mais départ orbeo caoutchouc par ce
départ au méthane ne veux pas exposer
leur vie ils veulent ils veulent avoir
avoir une vie normale mais il s'en fout
c'est justement un assaut à se prendre
en charge à se soulever contre cette
agression d'israël
aujourd'hui tu en fis thani clairement
la communauté internationale exprime son
inquiétude notamment la france ce soir
mais les états unis où on voit un peu
dissonante et condamne les tirs de
roquettes en cette fois-ci palestiniens
contre l'état hébreu
ça veut dire quoi qu'en gros il n'y a
pas vraiment de rupture avec joe biden
il est tout à fait sur la même ligne que
donald trump à 176,1
israélo-palestiniennes et rien
petite-ile différence parce que deux au
conseil de sécurité etats unis
aujourd'hui lundi une déclaration
publique n'est pas un départ importante
en ce moment donc il ya peut être un
petit peu de mais vous savez la france
aussi est là dans le communiqué de du
quai d'orsay qui a paru aujourd'hui il
est honteux
il commence d'abord par la condamnation
de tirs de roquettes
attendez les tirs de roquettes ne sait
absolument pas du tout la cause
palestinienne
mais commencer par cette condamnation
et puis on mettant sur le même pied
d'égalité les manifestants palestiniens
et puis la police qui les répriment et
puis les colons qui est qui manifestent
aux cris de mort aux arabes comme l'a
fait le communiqué du quai d'orsay c'est
honteux
mais pourquoi le font-ils taoufik tahani
pourquoi parle-t-il de ses tirs de
roquettes ils estiment peut-être que ces
voix là on a du mal à savoir qui
commence et c'est ça le fond de la
pensée on a du mal à comprendre c'est
pour ça que depuis tout à l'heure j'ai
dit comment ça a commencé j'ai parlé de
ce qui s'est passé dans la place devant
la porte de damas et puis
la manifestation des colons à jérusalem
demandant de tuer les arts et vous savez
quand il ya une très forte pression ça
peut exclure a explosé de partout ça
c'est vraiment celle élémentaires de la
physique et ça s'applique aux êtres
humains donc après il ya eu des vocables
hamas mais il y à gaza qui est sous
blocus infernal depuis très très
longtemps donc mais impossible de
maîtriser deux millions de de deux
personnes soumis à un blocus infernale
et c'est pour ça que j'ai dit tant que
la communauté internationale n'a pas
trouvé de solution à cette question
palestinienne
selon le droit international de la
légalité internationale
il va y avoir des problèmes or jusqu'à
maintenant on assiste à une
d'ailleurs la position des états unis
mais également celles de la france ou
union européenne
elles vont plutôt dans le sens 2 assurer
une impunité à israël ils ne sont pas
dans la logique de demander des comptes
à israël israël qu'il qualifie d' un
état d'apartheid et maintenant tout les
organismes sur les comptes
d'organisations internationales telles
que par exemple human rights watch ou
bien des organisations qui sera et vient
comme celle qui caractérise la politique
israélienne dans les territoires
palestiniens occupés ou bien en israël
même vis-à-vis de la mine ont été
palestiniens qu'en étant une politique
d'apartheid l'apartheid bien sûr toute
façon il va appeler des manifestations
de protestation et de temps en temps de
la violence de ceux qui sont sous
l'occupation
par contre d'ailleurs et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut vraiment faire faire la
différence entre ne pas faire vraiment
la symétrie entre les deux parties les
blessés quand vous parlais tout à
l'heure où dont le reportage de 300
blessés elle et 300 blessés ils sont
pratiquement tous palestiniens
il ya quelques blessés du côté des
forces de l'ordre dgl léger les forces
plutôt de deshors défense israélien mais
elle et ceux qui subissent la répression
sont les palestiniens les blessés sont
les palestiniens les neuf morts sur les
parisiens
la répression s'est pas laissée contre
les palestiniens
q c'est contre les palestiniens donc
cette asymétrie qui est servi par les
états unis et maintenant par la france
et un certain nombre de pays européens
elle est totalement fausse et merci
beaucoup taoufik thani d'avoir été avec
mon président d'honneur de l'association
france palestine solidarité merci
d'avoir été avec nous alors qu'il ya un
véritable regain de tension à jérusalem
est où on offre ce soir la mort de 9
personnes merci à vous